WITH AN ELECTION TO VOTE AND HOW
THAT AFFECTS TURNOUT.
>>> WE KNEW THERE WOULD NEVER BE
A FAIR TRIAL FOR MY FATHER AND
NOW THE WORLD KNOWS TOO.
THOSE WERE THE WORDS AFTER THE
COURT FOUND HIM GUILTY OF
TERRORISM RELATED CHARGES.
SENTENCED TO 25 YEARS IN PRISON.
THE MAN WHO INSPIRED THE FILM
"HOTEL RWANDA" LEFT HIS COUNTRY
BACK IN 1996 AND USES FAME, THE
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED SHAM.
FOLLOWING THIS STORY FROM DUBAI.
HIS LEGAL TEAM, HIS FAMILY
ALWAYS MAINTAINED THIS WAS NEVER
GOING TO BE A FAIR TRIAL, ELENI.
NOW THAT THEY EXPECTED IT.
WHAT MORE ARE THEY SAYING?
>> Reporter: I JUST GOT OFF THE
PHONE WITH HIS DAUGHTER,
CORINNE, EXTREMELY VOCAL SINCE
HER FATHER'S ARREST IN AUGUST OF
2020.
AND SHE SAYS THAT SHE'S NOT
SHOCKED.
THEY WERE EXPECTING THIS, SHE
SAYS, AND THEY ALSO KNEW THAT HE
WOULD BE CONDEMNED TO MANY YEARS
IN PRISON.
SHE SAYS THAT ONE GLIMMER OF
HOPE, THE BELGIAN AUTHORITIES
JUST RELEASED A STATEMENT SAYING
THAT BECAUSE THEY HAD REPEATEDLY
TRIED TO CONTACT RWANDAN
AUTHORITIES ABOUT THE TRIAL,
THEY CAN ONLY SURMISE THIS WAS
NOT A FAIR TRIAL AND THAT HAS
REALLY BEEN ECHOED BY SO MANY
TRIAL WATCHERS AND ALSO, OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS BRINGING TO
QUESTION FIRSTLY, HOW HE ENDED
UP IN RWANDA FROM HERE IN DUBAI,
BEING TRICKED AND LURED INTO
RWANDA AFTER THINKING HE WAS
BOARDING A PLANE.
HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH AT THE TIME
SAY IT WAS ENFORCED DETAINMENT.
SO THIS NOW TRIAL WITH THE
VERDICT THAT RELATES TO
TERRORISM CHARGES HAS BEEN
CRITICIZED EXTENSIVELY.
WE'VE EVEN INTERVIEWED THE
JUSTICE MINISTER AT THE TIME,
LARRY, AND WE ASK THE QUESTION,
IF THE EVIDENCE WAS SO
WATERPROOF, WHY NOT EXTRADITE
HIM THROUGH NORMAL PROCEEDINGS?
THE U.S. HAS ALSO VOICED THEIR
CONCERNS SAYING HE'S ILLEGALLY
DETAINED.
YOU'RE ALSO GOING TO UNDERSTAND
THE CONTEXT.
A MAN PROPELLED INTO THE
LIMELIGHT BECAUSE OF THE HELP
THAT HE OFFERED, OVER 1,000
RWANDA DURING THE GENOCIDE IN
1994 AND THEN ALSO VERY BIG
VOCAL CRITIC OF PRESIDENT PAUL
KAGAME.
MANY LAYERS TO THE STORY.
SOME SAY IT'S POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED BUT THE RWANDAN
GOVERNMENT SAID THE EVIDENCE IS
WATERPROOF.
TERRORISM RELATED CHARGES.
PAUL WAS PART OF AN OPPOSITION
GROUP THAT ALSO HAD A MILITARY
ARM AND THAT MILITARY ARM HAD
TAKEN RESPONSIBILITY FOR
TERRORIST ATTACKS WHERE YOU SAW
NINE PEOPLE DIE.
HE MAINTAINED THE INNOCENCE,
NEVER INVOLVED, BUT 20 OTHER
ACCUSED ALSO FACED TERRORISM
CHARGES AND OF COURSE, HAVE ALSO
BEEN SENTENCED.
>> ELENI GIOKOS, LEAVE IT THERE,
REALLY INTERESTING DEVELOPMENT
OUT OF THAT TRIAL